Guten Morgen Tim. Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim. Guten Morgen Dinos. Ah, jetzt haste. Wir wollten eigentlich.
Was denn? War doch gut. Meinst du? Was war jetzt falsch dran?
Meinst du? Dass du trotzdem wieder das Gleiche gesagt hast? Ich.
Aber andersrum.
Meinst du, das reicht schon als äh jetzt.
Soll ich denn sonst sagen?
Nee.
Willkommen zur äh jetzt zehnten Folge des Logbuchs.
So fangen wir jetzt an.
Wir machen jetzt einfach die Kamera läuft. Du hast, du gibst mir sonst auch nicht die Gelegenheit, irgendwie zu sagen, wir müssen das.
Das stimmt.
Nee, nee, nee. Ich habe schon so oft gesagt, also lass uns bitte rausschneiden. Tim, guck dir, war unerbindlich. Nein, nein, nein.
Ausgelassenheit macht sich hier breit. Das ist das ist die Vorstufe zur Nachlässigkeit.
Okay, wir wir machen jetzt hier ganz streng. Also, erstmal,
Hat einen Fehler gemacht bei der letzten Folge, die ja für uns gerade erst eine halbe Stunde her ist. Und zwar habe ich ganz vergessen, die Kampagne für Netzneutralität des Vereins digitale Gesellschaft zu erwähnen,
die nämlich auch beim achtundzwanzig C3 vorgestellt wurde,
Und zwar in einem Vortrag von Markus Beckerdal und Falk Lüke, die dort äh ausgeführt haben,
was sie denn da an den Start gebracht haben mit dem Verein digitale Gesellschaft, in dessen Umfeld ich ja auch aktiv bin, was ich da als Disclaimer sagen muss, da gibt's jetzt eine Webseite unter echtes Netz DE,
wo äh die Argumentation,
ähm zur zur Idee Netzneutralität und die Probleme ähm und auch die Entwicklung der letzten Jahre in diesem Themenbereich äh sehr schön wiedergegeben werden.
Kann das sein, dass das jetzt im Prinzip die erste wirkliche richtige Kampagne von der digitalen Gesellschaft ist?
Das ist zumindest die erste wirklich formierte in der Form Kampagne, die vor allem auch durch die Stiftung Bridge,
Ähm unterstützt wird, also durch die Bewegungsstiftung,
Die haben da, also da hatten wir einen Antrag formuliert und haben auch eine Unterstützung von, ich denke, das kann man sagen, das waren zehntausend Euro dafür bekommen.
Und mit dieser Seite echtes Netz soll das jetzt also quasi auf die Füße auf die Beine gestellt werden und das ist dann tatsächlich also kann man in der Form,
sagen, dass auf jeden Fall die erste richtig größere,
Kampagne, in der jetzt auch wirklich Leute zusammengesetzt werden, Plan entwickelt, äh wird und auf, sage ich mal, auf eine längere Zeit gedacht wird, die auch mal ein nennenswertes Budget hat,
Also schon auf jeden Fall die erste Kampagne, die diesen Namen hoffentlich am Ende dann auch verdient hat.
Ja und auch äh wirklich eine sehr attraktive Webseite, finde ich. Nicht, dass das jetzt unbedingt.
Forderlich sein muss, ja? Auf der anderen Seite, wenn man sich eh die Mühe gibt, äh, Sachen ins Netz zu stellen, warum dann nicht auch gleich ansprechend gestalten, um einfach auch Leute dort verweilen zu lassen, das finde ich,
sehr gut, weil ich habe eigentlich genug von diesen ganzen,
Kleinschrift Webseiten, die sich gar nicht groß bemühen, ja, um um Aufmerksamkeit.
Das ist so das Bashing. Ich habe vor äh vor einem Dreivierteljahr habe ich das neue Design von Netzpolitik org gemacht und seitdem kriege ich die immer oft um die Nase, äh wie hässlich diese Seite ist, die natürlich vorher auch schon hässlich war. Ähm,
Und die ähm wo ich auch zugebe, dass dieses Design wahrscheinlich nicht äh der des Grafikdesigns letzter Schluss ist, aber da kann ich äh sagen, ich.
Bist du da der Einzige, der dafür verantwortlich ist?
Nee, ich äh habe nach Vorlage gearbeitet. Ich habe eine Vorlage umgesetzt. Das heißt, ich bin da, ich kann da eigentlich meine Hände in in Unschuld waschen und habe äh nur das äh nur gesagt. Ich habe nur getan, was wir gesagt wurde und.
Nur getan, was mir gesagt wurde. Ich habe nur getan, was mir gesagt wurde. Wir wissen, so fängt's immer an.
Der Quelltext ist relativ sauber, wenn da nicht irgendwie vierundachtzig Plugins den sie wieder zerschießen würden.
Ja. Naja, ich denke, der Seite fehlt so ein bisschen Luft, ne. Also da da könnte man auf jeden Fall noch mal ein bisschen arbeiten. Aber wir wollen uns ja hier nicht so sehr über Webdesign unterhalten, sondern vielleicht bleiben wir nochmal kurz bei äh echtes Netz. Da ist ja auch,
finde ich den den Titel schon mal ganz interessant, ja, dass man an der Stelle auch betont, was ja,
Auch so eine typische, so ein Nerdsing ist, also ich betone das Beispiel gerne, wenn wenn ich so mit Leuten über die Probleme des Internets rede und vor allem über die konkreten Probleme des Internetzugangs, ja, wenn man so in Hotspots sich befindet, et cetera, dann äh,
diese ganzen.
Das ist kein echtes Internet.
Anmelden, Webseiten und äh äh Leute, die halt nur einen Browser bedienen, die die empfinden das nicht, ja. Die ziehen ja ihr iPad raus und loggen sich dann irgendwie ein,
von den konkreten technischen Einlockproblemen da jetzt mal äh bei der Telekom vor allem mal äh abgesehen, ist es halt einfach ein,
Drama, dass,
da was ist, was einem irgendwie in diese Datenströme greift. Ja, also kennst du das, man macht einen Browser äh startet man hoch, da hatte man dann irgendwie noch so dreißig äh Tabs auf zehn Fenster verteilt.
Und dann hast du in allen dieses.
Dann hast du überall diesen Loginscreen ja äh im schlimmsten Fall ist auch noch deine ganze Historie vergabelt oder du bist Mist, zwei Stunden damit beschäftigt den Backbutton zu drücken, das sind einfach so Sachen ähm,
Ja, ich möchte gar nicht anfangen mit irgendwelchen Reader-Racts, wo dann RSS-Rieder auf einmal ihre URLs ändern und also das das nimmt halt einfach alles Schaden. Also das muss einfach grundsätzlich verhindert werden, dass,
jemand mir also in den Datenstrom,
sehe, dass es da Usability Probleme gibt, äh das nicht so ohne weiteres gelöst ist. Ich sehe aber auf der anderen Seite auch nicht, dass man sich wirklich aktiv bemüht, das auch mal im Sinne des Nutzers zu lösen.
Ganz im Gegenteil. Also ich glaube da das also was,
Im Sinne des Nutzers, das ist ja, glaube ich, auch dieses Problem, gerade jetzt bei Netznetralität, da geht's ja dann noch um um viel gravierendere Dinge als jetzt irgendein Hotspot, wo ich eine äh Welcome-Page habe. Ähm.
Gerade da,
warum diese Seite jetzt oder warum echtes Netzwerks auch so gestartet wird mit quasi dieser äh Informationsseite erstmal zu erklären, was ist Netzneutralität und warum möchtest du das haben? Ähm.
Ist es, ich, also was, glaube ich, die Gefahr bei dieser Netzneutralitätssache ist, ist, dass gegen Netzneutralität viel ähm argumentiert werden kann, mit,
vermeintlichem Nutzerinteresse, weil die Leute in also die Leute TM ähm noch gar nicht so richtig.
Oder viele Menschen noch nicht so richtig eben diesen Netzblick oder dieses Netzverständnis haben, ja, also was wie es gab dieses schöne, was
vielen bekannt ist, äh berbel Höhen, bei Anne, äh Will, die dann sagte, ich gucke ja auch Internet und und Christopher Lauer von der Piratenpartei äh springt dann offensichtlich. Genau das ist es, sie gucken Internet, aber sie machen nicht Internet. Ja,
da steckt viel drin in dieser Sache, die in diesem kleinen Ausschnitt, wo man so viel drüberlacht und ähm langer Rede, kurzer Sinn, da jetzt,
Da soll's eben jetzt drum gehen und da da glaube ich, da wurden jetzt auf dieser Seite sehr schöne Dinge erstmal zur Aufklärung auch so zusammengetragen,
Wir verlinken da auch oder was heißt wir, ich hab diese Seite nicht gebastelt, deswegen sieht sie auch so schön aus, sehr schöne sehr schöne Kampagne auch von oder,
weiß gar nicht, ob das, ja doch, das ist eine Kampagne. Das geht, die gingen so aus von Steph und äh Jeremy, die da so im Lack vor der Tür umfällt auch äh zugange sind. Äh,
Verpetzt Seite für ähm Verstöße gegen Netzneutralität. Und ähm,
gleichzeitig dann werden ja dann da auch Tools angeboten, wo man also Hinweise auf äh Netzneutralitätsverstöße überhaupt erstmal vernünftig messen.
Man ja auch immer auf Deutsch starten. Ich habe schon eine geile Domäne im Namen.
Immer noch nicht, dieses Respekt, mein Netz auf Deutsch, ich meine.
Du meinst, dass es hier auch ein deutsches UI gibt? Ich sehe da hier.
Sollte es ein Deutsches geben? Na wenn ich auf Respekt mein Net dot IU gehe, dann kriege ich deutsch.
Achso, weil du deinen Browser auf Deutsch hast. Ich habe meinen Browser die folgt mir auf Englisch, aber ich kann hier nicht auf deutsch umschalten.
Ist auch noch nicht so hundertprozentig deutsch, aber es.
Werde das nochmal eine andere Domain äh.
Ja dann verrate ich jetzt mal nicht, sonst kauft sie wieder irgend so ein dumm,
Mähnrolle. Kennst du das? Ich ich habe einen. Ein Domentroll.
Wie du hast einen. Betreibst einen.
Ja, es, es gibt, ne, ich, nein, ich, es gibt jemanden, der eine Domain hat, äh die ähm.
Die mir zusteht. Ja und versucht, mich damit zu erpressen.
Aber da lache ich drüber. Das kann man ja machen. Für ihn ist sie wertlos. Insofern kriegt er auch kein Geld dafür.
Ja, ja, ne, ich habe auch noch so ein paar, die ich gerne hätte. Ich äh ärgere mich halt immer über Domains, die halt einfach partout nicht benutzt werden, so.
Und vor allem, dass selbst wenn man die dann irgendwie einmal im Jahr anschreibt und sagt so, hallo.
Gib doch mal.
Ja, irgendwie ein weiteres Jahr Verstrich und du hast es nicht benutzt, so, gib mal.
Na ja, ne, es ist auch äh vielleicht auch ja, fällt nicht unbedingt jetzt in das Thema Netzneutralität, aber so in dieses, wie die Dinge eigentlich zu sein haben, das ist natürlich das wiederkehrende Meme.
Vielleicht äh ich würde sagen, wir verweisen also jetzt auf diese Seite und auf diese Kampagne und hoffen, dass da jetzt im demnächst noch viel mehr zukommt.
Ich gucke mal, ob die Domänen, die ich gerade im Kopf habe, äh doch zu haben ist. Vielleicht hat sich das ja schon erledigt. Oh, ist bereits registriert. Ist schon weg.
Ansonsten kannst du mich ja damit registrieren. Ich dachte, ich kriege dann gleich eine E-Mail von dir mit zum Kaufangebot. Sag mal Linus, ich habe hier noch so eine dumme.
Ja, ich gucke mal, ob ich den kenne, der das hier irgendwie hält.
Ich erzähle in der Zwischenzeit nochmal kurz ähm,
machen wir noch wir gehen ja auch immer noch ein bisschen zurück, also Schultrojaner war ja auch schon ein Thema im Logbuch Netzpolitik der ähm,
wie Markus jetzt bloggte, soll zweitausendzwölf zunächst nicht zum Einsatz kommen. Da gab es eine Pressemitteilung der Kultusministerkonferenz, die sagen, also zweitausendzwölf kommt der erstmal nicht zum Einsatz und Alternativen sollen jetzt irgendwie diskutiert werden.
Ähm da gibt's dann irgendwie die Interpretation, dass sie einfach dieses Stück Software noch nicht fertig haben.
Mhm. Ähm also wer hat das gesagt, dass es nicht zum Einsatz kommt?
Zweitausendzwölf zunächst nicht zum Einsatz, in steht in einer Pressemitteilung der Kultusministerkonferenz.
Kultusministerkonferenz.
Welche ja diejenigen waren, die es ursprünglich auch mal so in der Form unterschrieben haben.
Und hast du den Eindruck, dass das dass diese Aussage auch schon was mit dem öffentlichen Druck zu tun hat? Oder denkst du einfach, das ist nicht umsetzen können und äh Business.
Sie geben da auf jeden Fall, also der Titel ihres Blogbeitrages heißt irgendwie Handlungsfähigkeit der Schulen, Datenschutz und Schutz des geistigen Eigentums oberstes Gebot. Also alle drei Dinge sind oberstes Gebot in,
ähm also da steht jetzt nicht irgendwie drin, dass es da einen großen äh Aufriss gab oder so, da steht eher lapidar, dass dass sie da nochmal ein weiteres Gespräch kommen sollen,
im ersten Quartal zweitausendzwölf wollen sie ein weiteres Gespräch führen und zweitausendzwölf soll jetzt erstmal nicht zum Einsatz kommen. Mögliche Alternativen diskutieren,
Aber sie sind sich natürlich einig, das geistige Eigentum schützen Rechte der Verlage, Autoren und so weiter. Äh Lehrerverbände werden in weitere Gespräche einbezogen, aber na ja, wenn die Lehrerverbände damit einbezogen werden, dann heißt es ja, dass zumindest irgendwie von deren.
Also ich lese jetzt mal so zwischen den Zeilen.
Zeilen liest man.
Da sind auf jeden Fall Klopfzeichen empfangen worden, also mindestens, ne? Es ist ja hier auch äh auf Landesebene thematisiert worden von der Piratenpartei im Parlament,
Und ähm ich denke, das ist wieder mal so ein Thema, das hat irgendwie keiner auf der Liste und jetzt sehen sie sich alle wieder damit konfrontiert, dass man sich dann doch mal damit beschäftigen sollte und dass da vielleicht äh es auch wertvoll ist, darüber nachzudenken,
am Ende macht das am Ende bringt das nochmal was, dass diese Piratenpartei jetzt mit dem Spiel ist. Derzeit hat man schon den Eindruck, dass zumindest viel Staub aufgewirbelt wird. Der kann sich auch widersetzen, ne.
Viel Staub auch um die Piratenpartei selber, weil es vielleicht noch ein anderes äh ein anderes Thema. Ähm.
Nächstes kurz, nächstes kurzes Thema, ist der.
Soll ich jetzt nochmal den Versprecher sagen? Save Online oder soll ich einfach mal direkt Stop-Online-Pire? Das ist ja so mein Flort. Der Stop-Online äh Piraty Act ähm,
da ist da, denke ich, ist auch der der Druck, der der da jetzt zu sehen ist. Das ist, glaube ich, für eine netzpolitisches Thema in den USA kann ich mich äh kaum erinnern, dass da mal so eine,
so ein Bohei stattgefunden hat. Also,
die Genoinentzpolitischen Themen und da ist es jetzt sogar so weit, dass sehr, sehr viele ursprüngliche Unterstützer, die irgendwie einer,
Allianz, die die dieses äh Gesetzesvorhaben ursprünglich mal unterstützt haben, angehört haben, sich da wirklich äh offen von Distanzieren, da austreten und so, das hatten wir auch schon ein bisschen besprochen,
Und jetzt diskutieren
So wird kolportiert sogar Google, Amazon und andere Anbieter, ähm ob sie ihre Seiten irgendwie für einen Tag abschalten, wenn dieses wenn dieses Gesetz irgendwie ähm tatsächlich zum Einsatz kommen sollte. Und ähm
Ich denke, so ein Blackout in der Form, vor allem mit diesen erstens mit mit diesen großen Anbietern an Bord und von denen auch.
Ins Gespräch gebracht. Äh ist, denke ich zumindest in dem Ausmaße auf jeden Fall das erste Mal, dass das sowas da stattfindet. Oder.
Jetzt schon einen festen Termin.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, aber die denken jetzt quasi denken darüber nach.
Aber allein schon, dass darüber nachgedacht wird, ist die Frage, wer da mitziehen würde.
Ja, also.
Von Google gehört, ich hab von Twitter gehört.
Amazon stand jetzt in einem Artikel auch. Jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, wie ernsthaft.
Also ich meine, eigentlich braucht man eigentlich braucht man nur Facebook.
Facebook, ja Facebook ist Facebook dabei, äh habe ich jetzt, glaube ich, nicht. Habe ich so nicht gesehen. Also.
Essential, weil ich meine, wenn Facebook noch läuft, dann gehen die Leute alle an ihren Computer und stellen fest, nee, das Internet geht noch.
Also in den Artikel, den ich jetzt grade mal sehe, steht das, steht Facebook auf jeden Fall nicht dabei,
Was auf jeden Fall nicht auszuschließen wäre, ne. Ähm,
ich wollte das jetzt erstmal nur so als äh Ruma mit einbringen
und nicht äh habe da jetzt nicht weiter so großartig zu recherchiert. Es wäre dann ohnehin die Frage, ob die ernsthaft, also Amazon
ähm einen Tag Umsatz, ob die ernsthaft darauf verzichten oder ob sie einfach so eine typische äh Clique hier, um doch dahin zu kommen, ähm.
Machen.
Schwarze intropage machen.
Also hundertprozentig runterfahren,
können sie glaube ich ihr System auch nicht, weil sie ja natürlich auch gegenüber Set Party da zahlreiche äh Verpflichtungen und Verträge haben, äh nicht mal also,
konkret Amazon, meine ich jetzt, ne? Amazon ist ja mehr als nur ein Webshop. Amazon ist ein,
Internetbetriebssystem, ja? Es ist also eins der Internetbetriebssysteme eine Cloud-Plattform, die,
einfach die ganze Zeit laufen muss und wenn sie die abschalten, dann kommen sie in Teufels Küche und natürlich vor allem kommen alle in Teufels Küche, die das nutzen.
Das wird aber, also das ist ja genau das Hauptinteresse Amazons in dieser Angelegenheit, ne, weil Amazon wäre ja als Betreiber dieser Amazon-Cloud äh dafür verantwortlich zu machen nach,
so paar Regeln, wenn jetzt jemand quasi sich Amazon bucht und dort ähm das nutzt, um.
Ja klar, aber wenn sie jetzt irgendwie jemanden den Zugang zu seinen Daten äh äh in dem Moment wegschnappen, wo er gerade äh äh den Deal seines Lebens macht. Ich meine, das steht sicherlich nicht, nicht in den Verträgen drin,
abschalten können, wenn sie gerade mal gegen irgendein Gesetz demonstrieren wollen. Von daher denke ich, haben sie da nicht die vollen Freiheiten. Auf der anderen Seite haben sie natürlich,
schon eine Menge Hebel, die sie im Prinzip bewegen können, wenn sie wirklich wollen. Also das äh denke ich.
Allein diese Ankündigung, denke ich, ist hier schon die politische Message.
Das denke ich nämlich auch.
Deswegen habe ich da, wie gesagt, jetzt auch gar nicht weiter großartig mir über Details Gedanken gemacht. Allein diese Ankündigung zu sagen, wir machen hier äh wir machen ja einmal.
Ja, ich meine, wenn man wenn man sich mal dieses Ding äh eines Generalstreiks, wie man das so im normalen Leben hat, ne, die Züge fahren nicht,
Was weiß ich, die Autobahn äh werden geschlossen, also öffentliche Infrastruktur wird lahmgelegt.
Genervt. Genau, ne. Müllabfuhr mal eine Woche, kommt mal nicht. Das bewirkt äh richtig was. Aber in zunehmenden Maße sind die Auswirkungen eines Internetgeneralstreiks,
krasser, ne? So die Frage, wer zieht da halt mit? Aber in dem Moment, wo sich eben zumindest von den Großen ähm,
viele auf so eine Maßnahme einigen und deswegen meinte ich halt grade, ne? Facebook äh müsste im Prinzip dabei sein, weil das wäre dann ein Instantana,
Na ja, Sinneswandel ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben, aber da,
wäre es zumindest klar, dass äh ein Großteil der Internetnutzer sofort diese Auswirkungen davon spüren würden und sich natürlich darüber Gedanken machen, ne? Und danach, vor allem, wenn da eine Webseite ist, äh heute kein Facebook,
Und hier ist übrigens die Telefonnummer auch von deinem zuständigen Kongress äh Abgeordneten auf Basis deiner IP-Adresse, weißt du? Äh da kannst du mal anrufen und fragen, wann's wieder eingeschaltet wird.
So und das äh ich glaube den Terror, den würden die da gar nicht überleben, ne? Auf der anderen Seite ist auch die Frage, ob sich das Facebook politisch so erlauben kann, ja, weil die natürlich auch eine ganze Menge, wir wissen ja, ne, äh Lobbyismus betreiben und natürlich jetzt auch kennen,
Interesse daran haben alle ihre politischen Kontakte von heute auf morgen zu verbrennen, aber das sind auf jeden Fall interessante äh Hebel.
Aber mit Lobbyismus sagst du schon, gibst du eigentlich das richtige Stichwort. Laut der Artikel, die ich jetzt hier so gelesen habe, kündigen Sie das an für den Fall, dass das Gesetz,
äh entschieden wird. Und ihr Interesse ist natürlich, dass dies nicht geschieht. Ja, also,
Auch in dem Falle oder auch unter unter unter dieser Lesart, die wollen das alle nicht machen, ja? Also ich glaube, die es ist wirklich diese Ankündigung, auf der hier das Gewicht liegt, ja, weil wenn das Gesetz äh entschieden wurde und sie dann irgendwie, dann ist eh egal, ja,
dann können sie sich auch sparen. Also wenn, dann müsste sie's eigentlich äh an dem Tag machen, wenn final darüber abgestimmt werden soll oder einen Tag vorher.
Aber wenn sie es mal wirklich mal alle und wenn's nur eine Stunde ist, ja, also so eine Stunde Internet-Schweigeminute.
Und Google keine Suche? Keine Googlesuche.
Google, sucht das selber.
Facebook-Login ja und ich meine, wenn die Großen sich einfach,
einig werden. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob sie das wirklich hinkriegen, ja? Und natürlich müssen sie bestimmte Subsysteme laufen lassen und natürlich sind ihre ganzen Party-Contract da und die Leute, die bei ihnen Webseiten äh laufen lassen, dürften davon nicht betroffen sein. Aber wir wissen ja alle,
Amazon, wenn die dichtmachen, plus Google plus Facebook. Ich meine, was sollen die Leute dann noch tun? Ja, müssen sich auf einmal mit richtiger Kommunikation und richtig,
im Internet irgendwie. Ja genau, twittern geht halt auch nicht, beziehungsweise die Systeme laufen halt alle, aber kommen halt alle nur mit so Fehlermeldungen und Hinweisen auf äh,
Tut mir leid, wir müssen jetzt hier grade mal demonstrieren und wenn du wissen willst, warum hier ist dein Kongressabgeordneter. Das wäre äh der Hammer. Ja, ich meine, da könnten, was weiß ich, auch die Journalisten nicht mehr arbeiten,
Weil sie irgendwie ihre Nachrufe nicht mehr erholen können und so weiter, die sie grade schreiben müssen. Also es ist.
Steht am besten, da kommt die leere Zeitung. Ja, wir haben uns mal entschieden, wir protestieren auch mal so gegen Sofa.
Aber es wäre natürlich dann die Nachrichten, ne? Das wäre dann wirklich äh im Boulevard, also der große Internet-Blackout, äh ne, Generalstreik und zwei.
Und als nächstes wird dann die Debatte losgehen, was diese Firmen äh an dieser Infrastrukturen, was die Firmen in dieser Infrastruktur für eine Macht genießen.
Ja. Trotzdem äh die Liste der Supporter ist auch nicht gerade kurz, wenn man die sich so anschaut, da sind natürlich vor allem viele Intellektual Poperty Unternehmen, aller Art drin, ne, Disney, et cetera. Die werden da sicherlich nicht mitspielen bei so einem Streik,
Aber äh was es für Auswirkungen haben kann, hat ja die zumindest gespürt, ja, die war ja auch auf dieser Unterstützerliste, also der größte DNS ähm,
Wie heißt es Registrat.
Dumm ist es nicht ein, also die bieten Domänen, Webhosting und Zertifikate machen die also ein ganz.
Ja, die registrieren das für dich.
Registriere.
Ja, sie machen auch noch andere Sachen, aber das ist halt das Wesentliche äh so. Du hast da halt deine äh deine Domains, die erwirbst du dort, du zahlst ihnen das,
sie das weiterreichen, damit sie die gehören,
Gut, der die Wahrheit auf dieser Supporterliste, dann gab's eben so von den Aktivisten, auf Twitter, et cetera ging das irgendwie rum, so hier, Goalie, die unterstützt so paar äh,
Ne? Und dann gab's halt andere Konkurrenten, die eben schnell gesagt haben, ja hier ist euer Coupon-Code, der gilt noch in einer Woche. Wenn ihr irgendwie eure Domains jetzt umziehen wollt, gibt's das schön billig und wir sind gegen Sofa und
das war jetzt nicht so, dass ihr alle Domenz losgeworden sind, aber es gab dann halt extrem viel Bewegung, nachdem äh Jimmy Wales angekündigt hat, dass halt sowohl die Wikipedia,
Ja, also irgendwie Media natürlich plus auch Wikia, alle ihre Domains, die sie wohl vorher tatsächlich bei Go, der dir äh gehalten haben, umgezogen hat.
Da merkte man ganz schnell, ne und kurz danach kam dann so schon so die ersten Meldungen so, hm na ja, äh wir überlegen uns das nochmal. Wobei äh das habe ich dann im Detail nicht verfolgt, aber es gab dann die Behauptung, sie hätten ihre Politik umgedreht, ja? Und sie wären jetzt dagegen,
ich hab dann allerdings ein paar Berichte gelesen, war hatte dann aber nicht mehr die Zeit,
Während des Kongresses dem dann so nachzugehen, aber es wurde so behauptet mit na ja das hätten sie jetzt zwar da mal irgendwie geblockt, getwittert, keine Ahnung,
aber äh sie hätten halt ihren Support offiziell noch nicht zurückgezogen. Vielleicht haben sie es mittlerweile getan.
Sie haben's äh tatsächlich, es gibt dann einen ähm Blogpost, wo sie sagen, ja äh wir haben auf unsere Kunden gehört und haben jetzt unsere ähm Go der die no longer Supports supe.
Das haben sie da geblockt,
aber der Support wurde zumindest zu dem Zeitpunkt, als sie das geblockt haben war, war dieser Rückzug noch nicht in den Kongress hinein vermittelt worden, ob das nun mittlerweile geschehen ist, das entzieht sich jetzt meiner Kenntnis
Dementsprechend wurde dann auch gleich nachgeheizt mit hier lasst euch nicht verarschen.
Es geht immer weiter. Also das ist schön und ich würde mir auch.
Effekte mal hier äh wünschen, ich meine bei Domains ist es halt insofern an der Stelle sieht man aber auch, was ein äh.
Wie sagt man, dereguliertes Netz.
Netz.
Vorteile hat, ja? Also äh wir haben ja über über Netzneutralität gesprochen, aber auch generell die generelle Problematik, dass du keine Alternativen hast, ja?
Äh ja, dieses kündige deinen Facebook-Account. Das ist das ist ja, das ist das ist Alternativ.
Man das?
Na ja, man kann das, nur in dem Moment verlierst du halt so viel und es ist nicht so, dass du dann zu einem anderen Provider äh umziehen kannst und der bietet dir das selbe, ja, das ist vielleicht jetzt nicht der beste Vergleich, aber an der Stelle merkt man das natürlich deutlich. Bei den Domains ist es so,
Es ist egal, welcher Firma du das Geld gibst dafür, dass diese Domains korrekt angemeldet sind. Du kannst da jederzeit umziehen. Das hat keinerlei unmittelbare Auswirkungen auf irgendwas.
Ja, das hat nur Auswirkungen auf den konkreten Kundensupport und vielleicht auch auf den Preis, den du bezahlst, aber
Es ist machbar, ohne dass du irgendwelche technischen Nachteile oder strukturellen Nachteile davon hast, weil das eigentlich nichts anderes ist, als eine Datenbank, äh die korrekt gepflegt wird. So und ähm,
wären,
auch alle anderen Komponenten des Internets immer so aufgestellt, wäre es sehr viel einfacher eben auch als Kunde äh entsprechenden Druck so auch auszuüben auf,
Dinge, die ihr einfach in die falsche Richtung geht. Internetservice-Provider, also jetzt hier so, was weiß ich, Kabel, Internet et cetera, wo das so deine einzige Option ist, ja, wo du nur einen Provider hast
der dann eben sagt, och, na ja, bitterer machen wir jetzt mal hier ein bisschen langsamer und äh Zugriff auf diese Webseite äh geht gar nicht. Das ist immer so ein Problem, ne? Und und das äh erstreckt sich jetzt auf immer mehr Bereiche
Hast du das zum Beispiel mit dem Amazon Kindle äh mitbekommen?
Der äh also dieser Kindle Fire, ja, diese iPad artige äh Geschichte ähm.
Der hat ja jetzt auch seinen eigenen App Store, den Amazon App Store. Und ich weiß nicht, ob das noch so ist, aber es war.
Ist ja ein Android-Gerät und der müsste.
Genau. Und wenn du auf den Google Android Market gegangen bist mit deinem Webbrowser, dann haben Sie die URL redirected auf Ihren App Store.
Ja.
Also das ist das ist schon wirklich mega hardcore und so etwas.
Muss einfach äh also das gehört einfach untersagt, ja, dass das sowas darf auf gar keinen Fall passieren.
Ah, das ist schon richtig.
Ja, das ist richtig mega Hardcore und äh aber das ist eben jetzt auch genau das, wovon wir reden, wenn wir von Netzneutralität sprechen, ne? Das sind so diese äh äh Dinge. Es ist eben ein sehr weites Feld. Sofern bin ich da auch mit dieser,
ähm zum echten Netz, was wir vorhin erwähnt haben, auch da einer Meinung zu sehen, wie das jetzt mit dem Sofa weitergeht,
kleines noch am Rande, ähm wurde mitgeteilt, auf Schwedisch heißt Sopa, so viel wie Garbic oder,
Sehr passend.
Ach, dieser och Mensch, der gerade äh in Schweden gibt's doch jetzt auch die Kopisten.
Oh ja, das ist auch ein äh schönes Thema.
Äh ein Thema, was wir nicht vorgesehen haben, aber ich sehe schon, wir reißen eh heute wieder die Zeit, da können wir die auch noch mit reinnehmen, oder? Ähm.
Ja das ist ja wirklich eine irre Geschichte. Das kommt aus auch aus diesem Telecomics Umfeld, wenn ich das richtig gesehen habe, Leute, die einfach äh gesagt haben, Falschering ist unsere Religion bitte anerkennen.
Missionarische Kirche des Koptimismus. Und haben gesagt, Wissen und Kommunikation sind heilig.
Und ähm wir glauben, dass dich kopieren äh der Wert einer einer Information steigt und deswegen ist das für uns eine religiöse Handlung und wir müssen das irgendwie machen.
Bricht natürlich mit der These der Szene, dass äh das Kopieren keinerlei Veränderungen herstellt, ne. Also ich meine, wenn Dinge da durch.
Ist ja auch Religion, ist Religion, da gibt's keine Thesen.
Ja, ja, genau. Da kann man beliebig äh argumentieren und man muss äh keinerlei Belege oder nachvollziehbare Argumentationen liefern. Das ist in der Tat richtig.
Ich glaube, dass mehr Menschen die Courage haben werden, sich als Komplimisten zu orten. Möglicherweise nicht in der Öffentlichkeit, aber zumindest gegenüber ihren Nächsten
Kopieren hat für viele immer noch ein Stigma. Viele Menschen haben Angst, dass sie eingesperrt werden, wenn sie kopieren und remixen. Ich hoffe, im Namen der Kopie, dass sich das ändern wird, sagt der Gründer.
Sehr schön. Die Priester werden Obst genannt. Ja, also die Koptimisten und ich bin jetzt mal sehr gespannt, ähm.
Also es ist natürlich, ich meine, es ist elegantes, elegantes Trollen, kann man wahrscheinlich am Ende sagen, aber oder ich wäre auf den ersten ähm,
den ersten wegen Religionsfreiheit freigesprochenen Falls in Schweden sehr gespannt
der äh was weiß ich, irgendwie sich groß äh groß Content vertreibt oder groß irgendwie Raubkopien vertreibt und dann sagt, ja, also sorry, hier Religionsfreiheit steht nun mal bei uns drin und.
Ja äh da können wir ja vielleicht auch mal drauf zu sprechen kommen. In Finanz sind ja nun auch gerade Netzsperren aktiv geworden.
Ja, sie war sogar relativ äh gezielter und zwar richten die sich gegen,
Seiten. Ja, da haben wir irgendwie eine eine Reihe, also dieses dieses Gesetz wurde schon im,
Ende Oktober zweitausendelf äh beschlossen und da haben sie gesagt, so äh die Seiten von Pirate Bay im Kampf gegen Urheberrechtsverletzungen, so müssen jetzt äh gesperrt werden von den Providern. Und das ist ähm jetzt in Kraft getreten.
In Fillern und dann war direkt die Seite der Electronic Front hier Finnland nicht mehr erreichbar.
Ja, ist die Frage, ob jetzt die Religionsfreiheit an der Stelle irgendwie zurückschlagen kann. So nach dem Motto, äh ihr müsst diese Sperren wieder aufheben, weil unsere freie Religionsausübung ist nicht gewährleistet, wie sollen wir denn dann kopieren? Ja, wahrscheinlich sagen die anderen.
Ja, da müssten jetzt nur die Koptimisten in Finnland anerkannt sein und nicht in Schweden.
Ja, das stimmt.
Also in Schweden können sie auch, aber sie, ich weiß nicht. Ich glaube, da da sind die Schweden ja immer ein bisschen beleidigt, die finden, wenn man sie verwechselt. Aber also man könnte jetzt auf jeden Fall versuchen, die die Kopimisten sollten sich natürlich jetzt irgendwie auch in in Finnland.
Möglichst schnell um Anerkennung ihrer Religion bemühen, ne?
Ja, auf jeden Fall äh macht's mal wieder ganz den Eindruck, dass Internetsperren auch genauso greifen, wie man das immer vorhergesehen hat. Der Kollateralschaden, der dauert äh lässt nicht lange auf sich warten,
Der mag hier auch nur temporär gewesen sein, aber der zack mal wieder sehr schön, wie schnell das doch äh gehen kann, ne. Ich war jetzt ehrlich gesagt etwas unvorbereitet auf diese,
beiden Themen nicht nur das, aber sozusagen auch auf die Tatsache, dass die Zenitsperren tatsächlich schon beschlossen gewesen sind
Ja, ich mir hier dem Artikel Netzpolitik äh glauben darf, ist das ja am sechsundzwanzigsten Oktober bereits äh umgesetzt worden. Das ist äh mir so ein bisschen entgangen. Das äh liegt aber auch,
Richtig sehe noch vor der Publikation äh unserer ersten Ausgabe, oder? Also wir sind eigentlich.
Hoffentlich, sonst wär's peinlich.
Unschuldig, ne? Ich gucke mal, ob wir das schon äh hätten behandeln müssen. Das erste Mal rausgekommen.
Achtundzwanzigster Oktober.
Glück gehabt.
Bleiben wir vielleicht bei einem Netzsperren Thema, wo ich mich hoffentlich ein bisschen besser darauf vorbereitet habe. Äh Weißrussland.
Äh Weißrussland, die Meldung ging erst irgendwie äh durch die Blogs, das Weißrussland, jetzt das Klicken auf äh auf ausländische Links verbieten würde. Das ist aber so nicht richtig,
Was also jetzt in Finnland äh in Finnland, in Weißrussland seit dem sechsten Januar Gesetz ist, ist also, dass es, es existiert eine Sperrliste mit pornografischen und extremistischen Angeboten.
Und die ist schon seit seit einiger Zeit auch in Behörden und Schulen wird sie angewendet,
Und darunter befindet sich auch so ein also darauf befindet sich auch Charta, Ninety Seven,
Also eine regierungskritische Seite und diese Netzsperren wurden jetzt ausgeweitet in Form von Strafen für Zugangsanbieter, die an öffentlichen Orten den Zugriff darauf,
ermöglichen. Während Medien.
Medien als nicht näher definierter Begriff weiterhin darauf zugreifen können. Und es geht also hauptsächlich, was wir, was wir hier jetzt also sehen, sie sagen Zugangsanbieter, die an öffentlichen Orten Zugriff erlauben. Das ist,
insbesondere dann für Internetcafés. So ein Problem,
Und da geht es jetzt, also gerade äh auf Internetcafés wird jetzt quasi dieser dieser Last der Providerhaftung so ein bisschen,
abgewälzt, indem man also sagt ein Internetcafe macht sich strafbar, wenn es auf solche Seiten,
Zugriff ermöglicht und ähm das Einzige, wie es da raus aus dieser Nummer rauskommen kann, ist, wenn es.
Quasi die Nutzer weiter überwacht und die das proaktiv meldet, also ein ein wenn ich jetzt ein Internetcafe betreib.
Geht gar nicht so sehr ums Sperren, sondern es geht ums Überwachen.
Genau, denn diese Sperrlisten, die gelten auch nicht für private Internetanflüsse.
Also privat wird da auch nicht eingesperrt, aber die Behörden dürfen mich natürlich überwachen,
Das heißt, sie haben letztendlich hat Weißrussland einfach die ähm,
die Leere gezogen, die wie gesagt in Tunesien und in anderen Ländern auch schon früher gezogen wurde. Es ist äh nicht schlau
zu sperren, aber es ist schlau, äh mähende Mittelattacken zum Beispiel zu fahren und äh zu sagen, lasst die Leute doch ihr Facebook nutzen, solange wir den Traffic irgendwie mitschneiden können.
Syrien ist da vor allem ganz vorne.
Zu sagen, lass die das nutzen, wir überwachen die einfach dadrin und dann haben wir unsere Pappenheimer besser unter Kontrolle, als wenn wir jetzt irgendwie sperren und dann sie das umgehen mit.
Ja, das war die ägyptische Lösung, die ist ja komplett nach hinten äh losgegangen. Die Libyer hatten die andere Variante, die haben einfach den Zugang verlangsamt,
bessere Überwachungstechnik, weil das dann zumindest schon mal so, dass man nicht sagen konnte, ist ja alles gesperrt. Aber wurde trotzdem unbenutzbar.
Genau und effektiv was, was also in Weißrussland jetzt,
Letztendlich passiert es, dass ich keine dass es keine Möglichkeit mehr geben soll oder die Möglichkeiten stark eingeschränkt werden,
anonym ins Internet zu kommen. Ja, weil ich kann's entweder von zu Hause machen,
oder ich kann es in einem Internetcafé machen, wo ich weiß, dass dieser Betreiber,
gesetzlich letztendlich dazu verpflichtet ist, mich irgendwie mein, meine Bewegung zu überwachen und zu speichern und sie von sich aus Behörden zur Verfügung zu stellen, wenn er nicht selber dafür irgendwie Probleme haben möchte
oder nicht selber dafür haften möchte und man muss auch dort äh,
quasi zum Nutzen eines dieser Internetcafe PCs seinen Personalausweis zeigen. Das heißt, so eine der eine dieser klassischen, äh ich gehe mal ins Internet, Möglichkeiten,
Ich gehe mal anonym ins Internetmöglichkeiten, das Internetcafés wird da also auch ausgemärzt. Und ja, privat ähm.
Liegt man dann sowieso schon der Überwachung. Wie jetzt diese ähm diese Idee, was ich gerade schon ansprach, dass man das dort,
ausländische Linksillegalisiert wurden, das war wie gesagt ein kleines Missverständnis und zwar hat Finla hat meine Güte, jetzt bin ich aber mit Finnland, hat Weißrussland da jetzt entschieden.
Das kommerzielle weißrussische Angebote, wie zum Beispiel Online-Shops, sich erstens registrieren müssen und zweitens in weißrussland hosten müssen,
und ähm das kann man natürlich, ist eigentlich vielleicht ganz interessant zu argumentieren, was sie da auch machen,
zwar wollen sie damit gegen,
Steuerflucht vorgehen. Augenscheinlich,
und sagen, wenn du irgendwie ein kommerzielles Angebot in Weißrussland hast, dann sollen deine Server auch hier stehen und du sollst gefälligst auch hier irgendwie deine deine Steuern zahlen und der Traffic und die Daten dürfen in die Weißrussland nicht verlassen. Äh was natürlich,
eine in eine interessante Methode ist, um eben diese Dateien oder diese Daten auch in der Möglichkeit des Zugriffs zu behalten.
Ja, beziehungsweise überhaupt erstmal die lokale Juristin, Juristiktion anzuwenden.
Interessante, interessante Argumente oder interessanter Weg. Ähm,
Was damit nicht so richtig erklärt werden kann, ist, warum neben der Steuerfahndung auch die Polizei und die Geheimpolizei äh irgendwie zuständig für Verstöße sind und diese Idee
was ein kommerzielles Angebot ist, ne? Das kann natürlich dann auch eine äh
Medienwebseite sein, die irgendwie Werbung schaltet oder sonst was. Also auch da irgendwie so ein Gesetz, was ähm.
Ja, was irgendwie gefährlich ist, ne und was ein großes Missbrauchspotential hat, ja? Wir wir hatten das ja schon mal angesprochen, was,
so Datenschutzforderungen angeht, dass das ja im quasi in Fragen des Datenschutzes,
Netzaktivisten, ein,
gespaltenes Verhältnis dazu haben, was es heißt, wenn Angebote in anderen Ländern sind, weil nämlich einerseits freut man sich irgendwie, dass äh dass man quasi die lokalen Gesetzgebungen durch dieses Internet gegeneinander ausspielen kann zugunsten der Netzfreiheit,
Ähm ich kann also ein Angebot, was ich hier in dem Land nicht mehr machen darf, mache ich einfach in einem anderen Land und komme trotzdem in dieses Land hinein. Andererseits sitzen natürlich Verbraucherschützer da und sagen, ähm ja Moment, äh Datenschutz muss aber irgendwie für uns alle gelten und deswegen ist äh haben wir jetzt mit Facebook ein Problem.
Weil weil wir irgendwie Facebook nicht in unsere Juristik irgendwie reinziehen können. Ähm,
Was weiß Russland da jetzt macht, die machen das natürlich nicht aus Datenschutzüberlegungen oder sonstigen, sondern weil sie irgendwie ihre äh Oppositionellen da unter Kontrolle halten wollen, ne. Das wird also
da sicherlich einen großen Missbrauch dieser Steueridee oder was auch immer. Äh,
geben, dass es vorhersehbar.
Weißrussland könnte nur mal so ein richtiger,
Kumbinationspunkt werden in Europa. Ich wundere mich ohnehin, warum die Diskussion äh über dieses Land nicht schon viel stärker äh,
Mittelpunkt gerückt ist, aber wenn sie jetzt wirklich im Bereich Internetzensur da vorliegen, dann äh,
kann man wieder schön auf weißrussische Verhältnisse verweisen, wenn die nächsten Pläne dann hier wieder kommen.
Interessant, ja, vor allem auch argumentativ, ne? Also sie sagen ja, sie argumentieren mit ihren Sperrlisten, argumentieren sie über pornografische Angebote.
Und über politischen Extremismus. Beides sind Wörter, die also zumindest, wenn es jetzt um kinderpornographische Angebote geht und äh rechts oder linksextremismus,
wo hier die Debatte ähnlich geführt werden kann, ja? Genau.
Also, das ist ja nichts Neues. Ich meine, eine ganze Zensurseler Debatte war äh im Prinzip, ne, auf der äh mit der Keule, wie man so schön sagt.
Und äh
wenn auch jetzt nicht so im Internetkontext, aber so dieses ganze äh Extremistengerede, ich meine, das haben wir in jeder Terrordiskussion und natürlich eigentlich auch schon jeder Internetregulationsdiskussion äh genauso, ne.
Und selbst wenn es so gemeint ist, ja? Ich glaube auch, dass viele Politiker, die da mag's eine Menge geben, die die die haben diese Talking Points äh so in der Tasche gespeichert,
ohne sich eigentlich darüber klar zu sein, was sie da eigentlich machen, weil sie sich zu dem Zeitpunkt schon längst äh von einer anderen,
Kultur instrumentalieren, instrumentalisieren lassen, ohne dass überhaupt zu begreifen.
Wir haben heute beide Sendungen, aber eins müssen wir jetzt noch ganz kurz äh zum Abschluss. Ähm also vielleicht noch um die äh Weißrussland Sache,
noch in in den Kontext zu setzen im letzten Jahr gab es da ja äh viele
Proteste und zwar gab's da diese stummen Proteste, wo die sich zu, so Klatsch äh Flashmobs.
Großartig.
Getroffen haben. Und die waren auch über soziale Netzwerke, dass es da in Weißrussland wird, äh Facebook und
V-Kontakte. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie man das irgendwie auf weißrussisch, russisch oder russisch ausspricht, äh genutzt. Da haben sie, glaube ich,
haben sie relativ viele Nutzer, viele Millionen Nutzer und auch Live-Journal irgendwie eine Millionen Blogger, die auf Live-Journal bloggen.
Mhm. Das ist ja eigentlich so schon immer im russischen russischsprachigen Bereich, so das System gewesen.
Und da ähm da haben sie genau auch festgestellt, das ist irgendwie jetzt zu groß
um das zu sperren, da kriegen wir irgendwie zu viel Ärger, haben wir fünf Minuten Leute auf der Straße
und deswegen Astroturfen sie jetzt da drin, also ähm haben halt wie in China Horden von äh Regimen, Supportern, die da äh die die Diskussion einfach kaputt rollen und äh schlagen dann diese Proteste nieder. Da gab's ja diesen schönen ähm,
Fall. Das hatte Fefe, glaube ich, geblockt, wo der einarmige für den äh für die Beteiligung an so einem Klatschflashmob äh verhaftet wurde.
Klatschen, ne? Kannst du nicht, kannst du nicht einfach klatschen, ist eine Frechheit so, ne.
Ja, also ich weiß nicht, vielleicht sind wir nochmal kurz erklären, was da passiert ist. Also dadurch, dass man natürlich mit lauten Protesten in der Straße sehr schnell in Trouble gerät, ja, äh ist man dazu übergegangen, dass,
System, beziehungsweise gar nicht konkret überhaupt irgendwas. Also einfach so zu klatschen, wie das halt auf den großen Veranstaltungen auch immer läuft, ne. So, wir klatschen schön für unseren geliebten Führer und so, kennen wir ja, ne. Es sei denn, er stirbt gerade. Da weinen wir uns irgendwie,
die Hüfte raus. Äh so und dann zogen halt massig Leute durch die Straße und klatschen einfach. Und das war natürlich,
Signal, das hat jeder irgendwie verstanden, das war dazu auch noch laut so, aber wofür sollte man die Leute so äh,
ja fürs Jubeln wird man jetzt auch schon eingesperrt, interessant, ne? Ist überzogen, ja.
Dem auch schon ja dann auch wieder entsprechend äh Aktivität entgegengestellt wurde. Ihr habt's jetzt im weiteren nicht so verfolgt, was da der Stand ist, ob da noch geklatscht wird. Ich glaube, das Klatschen ist jetzt,
mehr so ganz so angesagt.
Wenn sie sich also.
Aber Kreativität äh wird da sicherlich nicht versiegen.
Die Regierung hat da ja auch ähm wenig Verständnis für diesen Humor gezeichnet. Die haben, also die haben ja auch die klatschenden Leute einfach platt geklappt, gekloppt, so dass sind die relativ ähm problemlos.
Nicht zimperlich.
Nicht zimperlich. Ganz kurz noch, glaube ich, abschließend noch dieses eine,
dieses eine Thema noch anschneiden. Nazi-Leaks.
Punkt net.
Meine neue Leaks Plattform, die auch was tut.
Die aber äh bisher ihre Daten immerhin relativ schlechten äh
Formaten angeboten hat und vor allem jetzt auch irgendwie nicht erreichbar ist, aber die ziehen, glaube ich, grade einfach nur um. Also der Aufschrei, der enormes Aufschrei auf Twitter, den gab es nicht, insofern glaube ich, dass das offensichtlich irgendwie bei denen ähm.
Nach Plan verläuft, dass diese Seite gerade nicht erreichbar ist. Äh die Operation Blitzkrieg einiger Leute von die Daten sammeln, die primär aus Hacks von Naziseiten stammen.
Und damit Nazis entblößen. Also sie haben da, was haben wir da irgendwie die Kundendatenbank von Onlineshop von Tor Steiner,
setze ich da jetzt Unsinn? Ähm.
Ja, das ist.
Nationales Versandhaus NPD Spenderliste,
genau, die Kundendaten waren von Tor Steiner, Blood and onna, irgendwelche Adressen von Mitgliedern.
Ja, da wird natürlich schnell wieder geklatscht. Ich frage mich.
Wie man das bewerten soll. Also ich bin da sehr gespalten, ne? Das ist natürlich jetzt hier wieder die alte Diskussion, ne? Äh private Daten schützen,
Öffentliche Daten nützen so äh worum handelt es sich hier? Ja, ist äh das Anhängen des Ein Extremismus ausreichend Argumentation, um dann quasi die äh,
Datenschutzrechte wiederum aufzuheben dieser Leute, ja, also nur weil ich äh in Anführungsstrichen nur, weil ich einen Pullover gekauft habe, bin ich dafür dann auch automatisch Freiwillig, ja. Ich meine, es ist ja so, dass auch die Nazi-Szene,
schon seit Längerem mit der Methode arbeitet. Die linke Szene dadurch einzuschüchtern,
Adressen zu veröffentlichen und zu sagen hier das sind irgendwie die Linken, die wollen uns irgendwie als Fleisch nur dass das mal alle wissen und so und weiß der Geier, wir wollen ja hier nichts besonderes bewirken, aber ihr wisst schon, was ihr zu tun habt.
Gibt's irgendwie eine Liste linksradikaler Läden in den verschiedenen Stadtteilen Berlins zum Beispiel? Ja, gibt's irgendwelche.
Wenn aber auch irgendwann Personen immer wieder rausgepickt. Ich weiß nicht, ob's jemals.
Anti-Antifa, ja klar.
Ich weiß aber nicht, ob's irgendwie so konkrete Hacks gab, dann auch mit entsprechenden, ich meine, es gibt ja auch genug Klamottenläden, wo.
Antifa, Bekleidungsmaterial verkauft wird, würde jetzt das äh genau, das ist sicherlich auch nicht besser geschützt, wenn das jetzt äh gehackt wird und diese Liste liegt.
Was ist dann?
Schreien nämlich groß, dann wäre das.
Ja ja, ich meine, dann wäre das irgendwie Antifa Leaks und dann kann man natürlich lange argumentieren mit, na ja, aber das andere sind ja die Nazis und Nazis sind ja evil und weil sie Ivil sind,
gelten alle Regeln nicht mehr, ja? Da kommt man schwer vorwärts. Also ich bin ich bin mir in der Bewertung der Sache äh,
einfach nicht sicher, ne? Ist natürlich auch klar, was jetzt hier äh versucht wird, aber an sich reden wir ja hier von Hackerkrieg.
Absolut und also da kann man, denke ich, dieses Wort Internet-Pranger einfach auch mal so ähm,
nochmal hochholen und was hatten wir da? Da gab's ja äh auch schon gibt's dann immer mal wieder aus Polizeikreisen so,
Idee amerikanische Verhältnisse einzuführen, wo eben,
Täter,
irgendwie sich im Internet gesagt wird wo der der Triebtäter wohnt weil das eben von öffentlichen Interesse ist, sich von dieser Person fernzuhalten oder so. Und da ist natürlich auch denke ich aus gleichen Reihen der Aufschrei
und das auch zu Recht. Ja und,
diese diese Nazi-League so lang so so sehr man da eventuell äh versucht es klammheimlich äh sich drüber zu freuen.
Ist das ähm insgesamt eine Sache, die eben.
Die die Maxime, die dahinter steht, so etwas zu tun und da so einen Pranger hinzustellen ist erstmal moralisch auf jeden Fall ein größeres Problem.
Ja, doch, auch, auch,
auch fast die Legalität betrifft, finde ich, ist das also äh die Legitimität äh damit natürlich auch, weil das ist halt einfach,
da kann man dann lange über über Rechtsstaat einklagen, reden. Ja, wenn man an der Stelle äh das nicht genauso sieht.
Ich weiß auch nicht, ob das wirklich die Debatte um Nazis jetzt wirklich voranbringt. Ja, also ob das wirklich ein ein,
Mittel ist, was die Bekämpfung von Neonazi Gedanken gut in irgendeiner Form,
nennenswert, voranbringt. Also die Argumentationskette erschließt sich,
Nicht wirklich. Es ist halt immer so ein Einschüchtern der anderen Szene. Es ist so dieses na ja äh das hast du jetzt davon, dass du so denkst und fühlst, ja? Jetzt äh jetzt musst du die Konsequenzen tragen. Es ist eigentlich so ein digitales Verprügeln.
Ja, es ist er, aber,
also das einerseits schon, aber es gibt natürlich also es sind ja nicht Naziseiten sind ja nicht die einzigen, die gehackt werden, wo nachher die Accounts offen gestellt werden, weil äh es vorhatten wir das Gleiche, bei ähm,
bei diesem Sony Hack war ja dann auch die Frage, die diese Daten sind zwar jetzt nicht so irgendwie aufgetaucht unbedingt in der Form, aber es war irgendwie klar, die sind auch irgendwo, die hat jemand und natürlich ist auch derjenige, der da gehackt wird, ein Leidtragender,
ähm also der der Anbieter, sagen wir mal, wenn man also sagt
Guck mal hier, äh wenn du bei Tor Steiner äh bestellst, dann äh landest du auf Nazi liegst und jeder kann sehen, dass du irgendwie ins Kommentarfeld äh irgendwelche irgendwelchen nationalistischen Quatsch geschrieben hast und das kann kann sich jeder googeln und überleg dir doch lieber zweimal, ob du dir äh bei Tor Steiner,
deine Jacke bestellen möchtest, online,
das ist net das, diese Sache spielt ja natürlich auch noch rein, ne?
Ja gut, aber die Frage ist, ändert das viel?
Also ist das wirklich äh etwas, was, was, was, was wirklich was ändert? Und äh da habe ich äh meine Zweifel, dass das wirklich irgendwas bringt. Und zwar im äh im schlimmsten Fall, verschlimmert es die Situation nur, weil äh ich war, da sind wir im Prinzip,
schon im Bereich Gewalt und gegen Gewalt. Was ist das nächste? Ja, da haben wir wirklich Antifa Leaks, das wird.
Also.
Kommen. Mich hier nicht zu großen Prophezeiungen äh auch schon, ich sage nur.
Es gibt ja diese Sachen schon, also Anti-Anti.
Da ist so das ist halt das Ding, genau. Und auch die Nazis werden da technisch immer sicherer, ne? Und wenn man dann eben einfach.
Sicherer nicht. Also bis jetzt werden ihre Seiten immer aufgebohrt, aber äh.
Sicherheit, Entschuldigung, ich hab.
Versierte, die haben auch Ha.
Versiert da richtig, genau, also genau, die haben auch HK und so und es gab ja auch auf dem achtundzwanzig C drei äh eine wilde Diskussion, um einen äh Nazi.
Schwede war das.
Der in dem Fall ein Schwede war, da ging's wiederum, da hat's da hat sich das auch wiederum an der Kleidung interessanterweise wieder an Tor Steiner äh äh festgemacht, ja, jemand hatte halt irgendwie so eine Jacke an, dann gab's äh eine entsprechende Aufregung im Netz
ja, die man vielleicht auch äh nachvollziehen kann, natürlich dann immer wieder diese Debatte der Explosion letzten Endes äh war es wohl auch so, ich habe das alles nicht aus irgendeiner nennenswerten Nähe,
verfolgt, ach du hast es mitbekommen, na gut, dann halt dich mal das Maul und du erzählst.
Na, es kam also was du sagtest, weil also irgendwann
tauchte dann auf Twitter dieses Bild auf von jemanden, der ein sehr so ein Hemd anhatte, auf dem drauf stand und das hatte der auch schon auf der AK Vorrat-Demo davor und das war dann am am vierten Tage
dass äh das dann tatsächlich auch so weit hochkochte, dass das nicht mehr zu ignorieren war und ähm,
Genau gab's diese Debatte, ne? Lässt man diesen Nazi irgendwie jetzt hier an diesem Kongress teilhaben oder nicht? Und äh was dann letztendlich gemacht wurde, da.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, da ich mit den betroffenen Personen nicht gesprochen habe. Also eine Person, das äh eine,
führende Person des CCC. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob ich die ihren äh den Namen dieser Person nennen darf oder nicht. Deswegen mache ich's mal nicht. Ähm hat
hat dann diesen, diesen Menschen angesprochen und gesagt, pass mal auf, so, du trägst jetzt hier schon seit mehreren Tagen dieses Outfit und das äh hat in Deutschland äh diese und jene Bewandtnis,
was ja ganz klar ist, Frau Steiner ist nicht nur ein Label, was Nazis gerne tragen, sondern auch eine äh Firma, die aktiv Nazi äh Strukturen unterstützt mit dem Geld, was dadurch eingenommen wird und aus diesem Grunde möchten wir dich bitten, das nicht zu tragen,
woraufhin er dann sagte, ja gar kein Problem, dann ziehe ich jetzt einfach meine Jacke über das Tor Steinerhemd. Auf dieser Jacke stand dann Thor Steiner,
und er hatte auch noch net vor Steiner Hose an, also der mit dem Jungen war nichts mehr zu machen so, also man hätte äh wir hatten dann erst noch.
Debattiert, ob wir sagen, okay, wir schenken ihm, wir schmeißen zusammen und schenken ihm so ein äh so ein Hoodie vom Kongress, ne, so ein achtundzwanzig C drei Hoodie, die gibt's
Da zu kaufen, habe ich noch gesagt, komm, dann machen wir kurz eine Sammelung, dann gehen wir hier einmal rund ums BCC, haben wir in kürzester Zeit äh können wir ihm noch einen Hoodie schenken. Das wäre so so die Umarmungsaktion gewesen, ne? Und leider
muss ich jetzt dazu sagen, der Typ, der bei sich seiner Provokation absolut bewusst. Also es war jetzt nicht irgendwie ein Schwede, der versehentlich äh beim falschen Label gekauft hatte, ne. Der hatte auch irgendwie die,
irgendwie ein Millimeter Haare und ähm das war einfach das war Nazi so. Da gibt's nichts zu tun. Und er hat dann ähm.
Immer so, nur so, warum gesagt und irgendwie so mit so einem etwas höhnischen, höhnischen Hundeblick irgendwie so geguckt, so, ja, ich gehe ja gleich, aber ich kann doch jetzt noch, guck mal, ich ziehe meine Jacke drüber und hat also sehr provoziert, obwohl vier Personen,
wirklich um ihn herum standen und eine Person davon, wie gesagt.
Exponiertes Gesicht des CCC, jemand der auf diesem Kongress da bekannt ist und auch äh was zu sagen hat. Ähm diese Person dann da auch noch irgendwie ja mit mit seinem Blick so ja verarscht,
und der war sich seine Provokation ganz klar bewusst und dieses Gespräch endete dann damit, äh dass gesagt wurde, okay, da möchten wir dich jetzt bitten, zu gehen,
Dann wurde er ähm aus dem Gebäude eskortiert. Und wurde dann auch fortan nicht mehr gesehen.
Da hat er dann aber auch keinen Widerstand oder Argumentation.
Er hat sowieso, das war, das war das das dreiste, also er hat überhaupt gar keine Argumentation geäußert, er nur sowieso,
Warum? Warum darf ich das nicht tragen? Also auf Englisch warum?
Nichts, nicht irgendwie, hat sich auch nicht bestürzt darüber gezeigt, dass das irgendwie äh Nazikleidung wäre oder so, ne, wie.
Okay, also deine deine Sicht, dass er sich dessen voll bewusst war, ziehst du einfach aus dieser Reaktion. Das ist nicht so, dass er das dann noch irgendwie.
Er hat dann jetzt nicht irgendwie einen Hitlergruß gemacht oder,
aber ähm wenn wenn ich als jemand, der
der das nicht wüsste oder der damit ein Problem hat oder der nicht explizit Nazi ist, von vier Personen damit konfrontiert werde, dass ich Nazi äh Klamotten trage. Und ich reagiere einfach nur damit und sage so, ja,
Wieso soll ich die jetzt ausziehen? Ähm damit ist ja klar, dass ich mir dessen ganz relativ bewusst bin, ja.
Naja, also man muss äh ich meine
in der in der in der äh hektischen Twitter äh äh Debatte, die natürlich dann wieder gab's da natürlich dann gleich wieder die äh passenden Aufreger und überhaupt und der CCC und früher war alles besser und so weiter
einfach jetzt ein Problem, dadurch dass man natürlich bekannter ist und mehr unter Beobachtung steht,
steht man auch unter Beobachtung und unter Beteiligung von Leuten, die man vielleicht gar nicht so einhergeht, weil es gibt auch auf Naziwebseiten Berichte vom Kongress, wo irgendwie
mit großer Begeisterung darüber berichtet wird, dass es irgendwie einen Weg gibt,
SMS zu detekten et cetera, ja? Also das das ist äh schon also auch die Nazi,
Szene äh ist sich quasi der Überwachung und der, der, der Bordmittel der Polizei äh gewahr und versucht auch,
da wo das äh die entsprechende technische Kenntnis vorliegt, gegen vorzugehen und da sind natürlich auch Kongressvorträge sehr,
Willkommen, ne? Da muss man sich einfach keine Illusion machen. Das ist das ist einfach die Wahrheit, ne? In dem Moment, wo ich meine jetzt kann man ja sagen, okay, alles klar, jetzt haben wir da ein Nazi entdeckt, weil der jetzt einfach mal,
mit der mit der passenden Uniform durch die Gegend gelaufen ist, ja, weiß der Geier, wie viele da noch rumliefen. Gut.
Da kann man dann halt auch nichts gegen machen, ja. Ich meine, was,
wollen wir erst einen Gesinnungstest am am Eingang durchführen, das das ist unmöglich. Das ist äh auch überhaupt nicht wünschenswert. Und äh sicherlich muss man sich damit auseinandersetzen, auf der anderen Seite lässt sich das wahrscheinlich auch alles nicht verhindern.
Äh ich denke zumindest, dass dass man doch in der Lage sein sollte, relativ klar sowas mit einer, mit einer
was weiß ich, Kongress oder Hausordnung oder sonst was irgendwie abzudecken, dass man sagt, zumindest so äh solcher Einstellungen ähm verurteilen wir oder
wünschen wir nicht, ja? Und dass man ähm natürlich gibt, dass dann auch im im Umfeld der äh irgendwelche Debatten, wenn man sagt, ja hier man darf wir schließen Tor Steiner Klamotten aus ähm,
Ich denke, dass da aber schon, da wird sich letztendlich am Ende eine Mehrheit für finden, dass es da.
Ja sicher, ich meine äh eine Unvereinbarkeits äh Erklärung des CCC äh gab es schon vor Jahren und ich meine, das ist auch vollkommen unumstritten, dass dass man dieses Selbstverständnis hat im Glück
weil ich meine kann sich noch für so breit aufgestellt äh erachten und beschreiben, es ist vollkommen klar, dass natürlich auch ein Club äh einfach
linke Denkweisen vorherrschen, gar keine Frage. Ja, das ist äh deckt ein breites Spektrum ab, aber äh auf keinen Fall ähm,
sind äh ist rechtes Gedankengut in irgendeiner Form dort äh willkommen und es findet da auch keinen Nährboden, ja. Das ist vollkommen klar.
Vielleicht noch, wenn wir jetzt schon bei den, bei den Trollattacken gegen den achtundzwanzig C drei sind, gab's ja noch die Genderdebatte, die ist gerade auch sehr groß, denke ich.
Ähm,
Da gab's also glaube ich zwei Zwischenfälle, wo sich, glaube ich, sehr äh sehr klar eine Respektlosigkeit gegenüber Frauen,
stattgefunden hat und zwar auf der Bühne oder vom Publikum gegenüber Personen auf der Bühne
und äh auch da muss natürlich jetzt der, also auch das ist natürlich genauso wenig zu akzeptieren. Aber da damit wird jetzt grade der der Club so ein bisschen getreut, ne? Da gibt's jetzt die Pads und die, die äh die Twitter-Trolle und so und da
Finde ich in dem Fall jetzt gar nicht so schlecht. Das äh dass diese Sachen mal hochgekocht sind.
Und dass äh dass sich jetzt für zukünftige Veranstaltungen irgendwie sicherlich Gedanken gemacht werden, wie mit in welcher Form das
festzulegen ist, wie mit sowas äh umzugehen ist. Und dass man, dass man sich das in Zukunft nicht gefallen ist, weil es weil beides dem Selbstverständnis des Clubs in keiner Form entspricht und
auch nicht im Interesse des Klubs ist und dass dass da der Club natürlich auch sehr gut mit gestichelt werden kann.
Ja, da ist es ja auch äh in der Piratenpartei äh eine ähnliche ähnlich schwierige Debatte, ne. Ich meine jetzt äh
der Hackerszene jetzt pauschal pauschal Frauenfeindlichkeit zu unterstellen, ist sicherlich äh unangemessen. Ähm über Jahre wurde immer viel darüber nachgedacht und diskutiert, wie man da die Situation verbessern kann,
keine Patentlösung äh gefunden. Die Fälle, die du jetzt ansprichst, die waren auch wirklich krass. Also, ich meine, das war einfach,
Sagen wir mal, es war äh das Ergebnis einer einer einer generellen Gedankenlosigkeit, glaube ich, um,
Wirkung der eigenen Kommentare und das ist dann sicherlich auch schon geboren, aus so einem,
männlich, zentrierten Weltbild, was sich einfach zwangsläufig auch äh verfestigt, wenn man eben in einer Szene ist, die einfach neunzig Prozent oder mehr äh aus Männern besteht,
dass dass es auch schwierig sich daraus zu befreien, aber dass da die Debatte aufkommt ist sicherlich zu begrüßen.
Vielleicht werden wir gerade schon über so einen Frauen sagen, noch ganz kurz hier äh auf die netten Frauen vom Netzfeminismus Punkt org verwiesen,
schöne Internetseite, wo so viele Frauen ähm dieses und das ist auch eine ganze Liste, wenn man sich das mal anschaut, ähm,
die da, die da eine Seite betreiben und auch so ein Block roll haben von Leuten,
auf die sie da verweisen und und so viele äh wenige, so wenige Netzfeministinnen sind das nämlich auch eigentlich gar nicht. Und da gibt's also eine schöne schöne Webseite.
Die für alle interessant ist und auch in Berlin dann diese,
das Netz feministische Bier mit der schönen Regelung, dass man dass Männer dort nur hinkommen dürfen, wenn sie eine Frau finden, die sie begleitet.
Oder von einer mitgenommen werden, je nachdem wie die aktive Rolle.
Entschuldigung, Entschuldigung, genau das.
Wenn eine Frau sie mitnimmt, Entschuldigung, ja, aber dann sieht man genau, was mein Problem bei der Angelegenheit war, ja, ja.
Da wurde ich erwischt, ja klar. Genau, eine Frau, die sie, die bereit ist, sie dorthin zu begleiten.
Haben wir wieder ausreichend überzogen? Haben wir? Ja. Nochmal schnell kurz, nochmal eine kurze Sendung, sagtest du vorhin, ne?
Ja also uns gehen die Themen nicht aus, es ist gut, von daher sehe ich da auch sehr.
Positiv hier in unsere Podcast Zukunft für dieses Jahr. Wir müssen sicherlich darüber nachdenken wie wir unser Zeitmanagement besser in den Griff kriegen. Heute war es nochmal episch. Wir haben ja jetzt dann doch den ganzen Tag mit den beiden,
Sendungen zugebracht, aber ich glaube, das hat auch ein bisschen was damit zu tun, dass wir uns natürlich auch hier äh immer wieder, wenn wir aufeinander treffen, darüber Gedanken machen, wie man das Thema hier noch weiter äh entwickeln kann. Grundsätzlich
denke ich, haben wir hier schon mal ein Format gefunden, was so ganz gut funktioniert
Ich hab einige Rückmeldungen auch bekommen gerade jetzt auf dem Kongress aber auch außerhalb des Kongresses zu dem Podcast da freu ich mich natürlich besonders drüber.
Ich habe mich sehr gefreut über Getränke, die mir ausgegeben wurden. Das ist also sehr angenehme Nebeneffekt des Podcastens, dass man Getränke ausgegeben bekommt. Kann ich nur empfehlen. Und vielen Dank nochmal.
An alle, die uns unterstützen. Genau, auch per Flattor oder durch kluge Kommentare und vor allem durch Berichtigungen unserer äh fehlgeleiteten Kommunikation. Fein, das war's. Auf Wiederhören. Bis bald.
Auf Wiederhören.